let's talk a little bit about economics
there is this general Republican
economic fear mongering that exists in
many areas so for example the right will
tell you if you don't cut taxes for the
rich or if you raise them really bad
things will happen well no well actually
trickle-down economics makes no sense
we've debunked it many many times if you
raise the minimum wage reasonably not to
$200 an hour but reasonably it's going
to kill jobs well no actually we've seen
that in San Francisco County even within
the fast-food sector the minimum wage
has been raised above and beyond what is
actually required by the state of
California it has had no negative impact
on jobs and we heard from the right that
if you pass paid sick leave jobs we'll
be killed
well the great thing is we now have data
about this in 2013 the New York City
Council decided to go against what then
Mayor Michael Bloomberg wanted and they
passed something called the earned sick
time Act in 2014 under governor under
mayor rather bill de blasio the law was
expanded to cover all businesses with at
least five workers as opposed to just 15
workers as previously required the
initial passage of this law and its
modification in 2014 we're both
fear-mongering about by the
right-wingers saying this is going to
kill jobs
this will prevent jobs in new york city
from being created well we now have
several years of data to look at to see
if the prediction was true I'm going to
cut to the punchline for you it wasn't
true according to a new paper from the
Center for Economic and Policy Research
mandatory paid sick time was basically a
non-event even though more than three in
four employees at the surveyed firms
made use of paid sick leave in 2005 what
is underlying this well there are a
number of really really interesting
findings number one workplace illness
big picture is actually not a big
problem right so by giving employees
paid sick leave because employee illness
is not a huge issue fortunately
it actually didn't really impact hiring
it didn't really impact businesses in a
negative negative way number two most
employers already offer paid sick leave
without having been required to do so by
the law so most companies the law
changes and says you now have to offer
paid sick leave
most companies say well we were already
doing that it doesn't affect us at all
and lastly and this actually isn't good
the study determined that workers go to
work sick just as often when you have
paid sick leave as when you don't and
that's actually a really bad thing you
don't want your employees coming in sick
for forcing people to come in to work
sick is a bad idea all the way around
they get other employees sick they will
work below their productivity because
they are ill they're going to prolong
their illness rather than be resting so
very very interesting data here the the
highlight for me is the Republican
economic fear-mongering did not come
true and that has sort of become
expected in many ways but the other
interesting aspect of this that whether
or not you have mandatory paid sick time
employees come to work and they will
come to work sick in many cases and that
is actually not a good thing